I was born a very normal family and poor
family six people
sure $7 mouth we can only eat one
chicken a year what's terrible having
money isn't enough people the problem
saw be able to deal with adversity
that's the game I'm not actually good at
being resourceful I'm getting better
rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
have grand visions over to you Simon
sonic I was born a very normal family
and poor family six people
sure $7 a mouth we can only eat the one
chicken a year what's terrible Nixon
visits in my city 1972 China USA signed
a Mao Zedong Nixon Sunday Agreement so
China become open dole my City Council
was one of the first the cities that
opened to the west we got a lot of
American tourists to visit my city what
he would do is he would befriend foreign
visitors who came to Hangzhou to walk
around the west lake there and I learned
English by being the free guide for tour
guide you know more than the language
Jack was learning about the culture the
things I learn from books from China are
so different from the things I learned
from the American visitors so I start to
think differentially resourcefulness is
the ultimate resource so many people
focus on what they don't have the
resources they don't have the money they
don't have the education they don't have
the access to connections that they
don't have instead of focusing on what
they actually do have and how to turn
that into something amazing one of my
favorite quotes is from Steve Wozniak
co-founder of Apple and he said instead
of focusing on the things that you don't
have
focus on what you can do with what you
do have that's the definition of
resourceful Ness if you look at the
people who've done great things look at
the people who you look up to in
whatever whenever field athletics
entrepreneurship whatever the thing is
it's very rare that the kids of great
people go on to do great things it's
very rare it's very rare that the person
you love the your hero your idol your
role model in whatever field it's very
rare that they came from there the kids
of somebody who's done amazing things
this is somebody ideally other people
have all the resources in the world all
the opportunities in the world here very
very of the ones who go on to do
actually amazing things because the
struggle the battle for resourcefulness
is the game because having money isn't
enough be able to problem-solve be able
to deal with adversity that's the game
and you learn that through difficulties
when it's all lined up for you on a
silver platter you never learn those
skills I look at this YouTube channel as
an example when I started it I did
everything myself I film myself I had my
own camera I sucked I edited myself I
sucked everything was really bad and as
I started making more money I started
making some money and then more money I
invested it right back into the team
into the channel to building it up my
first hire was my editor which allowed
me to go from making a video a week to
video a day because he was better at it
than I was and it allowed me to do the
thing that I was better and that I
really enjoyed here's what most people
do most people they go out they think
it's a resource issue they go out and
then they hire that editor they hire
there they buy the lights and they get
the camera they get all the gear they
get it all set up and then they realize
oh you know what I'm not even I'm not
interested in YouTube I don't want to
that's not the thing I want to do and
you've invested all this gear so many
people do the same thing with other
businesses they want to be in t-shirts
and they make a design and there's gonna
be the sickest design it's gonna kill it
on the order of 10,000 t-shirts and they
sell three and the other nine thousand
997 are stuck in your basement apartment
or your mom's garage it's never about
the resources you have the ultimate
resource is your resourcefulness my
favorite story around this is still
Oprah Winfrey Oprah Winfrey came from an
insane family
you know wasn't raised by her parent
she's rained by her grandmother she was
you know abused growing up she had no
money super poor dirt poor her
grandmother bought potatoes used the
bags to sew her a dress so she went to
school in a potato dress basically you
can imagine going to showing up at
school could you imagine going showing
up at school in a potato bag because he
had no money to actually have a dress
you want to ridicule that she went
through and if she could go from that to
where she is what's your Excuse the
problem for everybody the problem for
you is you're just focusing on what you
don't have you're focusing on the wrong
thing if you focus on lack you're just
gonna find more luck and just gonna find
more excuses and more reasons why you're
not successful but if you focus on if
she can do it why can't I and you focus
on I already have a lot of great tools
for most of you you're living in America
you're living in the richest country in
the world you're complaining about what
you have internet what are you
complaining about you have more
resources at your disposal than any
entrepreneur that came before you it's
crazy so what are you complaining about
if what what can go from here to there
what's your Excuse and if you don't like
Oprah great whoever you look up to who's
your hero who is your entrepreneurial
athletic singing hero whoever it is look
at their story because chances are they
came from less than what you already
have right now and as long as you're
focusing on the lack of resources you
will stay in the mentality of lack as
opposed to saying I'm gonna find my way
out of this I'm gonna win I'm gonna
better myself
I already have everything I need to win
and I'm gonna show the world because
that's what they did that's what the
winners do now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that I want to know
what is your greatest resource that you
actually have right now let's focus on
what you do have and what you can do
with it what's the greatest resource at
your disposal right now feel it and put
in the comments below I want to see it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
I spray so give me go
music is my passion man production
besides the actual art of rap and I want
a lot I want to accomplish on the
production and the production side I
would love to try my hand and acting my
mother's an actress she tells me all the
time and she thinks to send me she's
been telling me that for years boy
you're an actor I'm telling you she
tells me you know so I would love to try
my hand at daddy I mean you use your
accents I mean you probably could call
Will Smith and get some advice okay
that's very I could do you do this I
have the connection at least to do it I
don't I guess cuz I'm not passionate
about it yet it's just a thought but
hopefully when I when I become passion
and I when I take it serious I would use
that car you just gave me the car to use
you gave me the idea for it so but yeah
I do have access I'm not actually good
at being resourceful I'm getting better
that's another thing to be a great
businessman I think you have to be
incredibly resourceful I'm new to
business period I never was good with
money
so having money is new to me and
therefore using my resources being a
great businessman is is new to me I'm a
self-taught filmmaker I never went to
film school I never studied filmmaking
in any way I started making films when I
was a kid when I was think seven years
old making films using my dad's super 8
camera and action figures doing
stop-motion films a little bit of
animation and a set amount of live
action and I just carried on making
films as I grew up and over the years
they got bigger hopefully better but but
more elaborate and there never really
was a period in my life where I
completely stopped doing it so I was
always moving up eventually from super 8
to 16 millimeter films and then I think
what following represents is kind of the
the peak of what I was able to do on my
own or just with friends just using our
own resources and foreign equipment and
sort of using the things around us to
make a program when I was 16 I I got
this job working for a newspaper in
Houston and my job was to sell
subscriptions to the paper on the
telephone and I realized too
new things when I was doing this I
realized that people that were buying
the newspaper generally had two things
in common either they were moving to a
new residence or they were getting
married and it turns out that you could
go find information about both of those
things in enormous quantities so in the
state that I lived in in Texas when you
get it when you want to get a marriage
license you have to file with the state
and it's public information particularly
the address that you want the license
sent to once it's issued so I hired all
my friends and went to every county in
the surrounding 16 counties in Houston
captured the addresses of all the people
that applied for marriage licenses and
sent them a direct mail offer to offer
them the newspaper for a free trial
meant a subscription and it ended up
making a making a fair sum of money for
a teenager the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details